also bringing some window controls from
some high-profile firms who struck on
dolly
[Applause]
[Music]
although me y'all know I earn a living
I'll catch this broad for you but it
ain't gonna be easy it's a bad [ __ ] I
like going down to social media and
chasing down Jack Dorsey's or Zuckerberg
now this was this key to swallow your
channels old prescriptions you know the
lesions and down you go now we're gonna
do it quick got to bring back Kol your
rightful subscribers and convert them to
mug clubbers on a paying basis but it's
not gonna be pleasant
all right value my channel hold up more
than 3,000 bucks chief I'll find her for
three but I'll bring my half asian
lawyer and Sewer for ten now you gotta
make up your minds you want to keep your
channels alive and any up you want to
play it cheap you'll be on - common gap
the whole winter I don't want no go fund
me I don't want no patreon is there too
many damn whiny conservatives on this
platform ten thousand dollars from me
and my half asian lawyer bill Richman by
ourselves so that you get the head
schnauzer whole damn thing thank you
very much YouTube Quint will well take
it on advisement mr. mayor
chief ladies and zeez
[Music]
lahter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the evil villain who can't
contain himself because his plot is so
evil I want to be coming collected but
it's difficult because this show was
amazing today we have Daniel Cormier yes
one of the best athletes on the face of
the planet
right now on that you could argue
someone else but it'd be pretty hard as
far as accomplishing if you don't Gavin
McInnes on the show Wow potentially a
future Senator Richard painter on the
show hello and I'm a club film review
and Dennis Rodman Wow oh yeah before we
move on with the show question of the
day because we're going to talk it we're
gonna be kind of roast in a sacred cow
today and public school teachers can you
name me how many teachers you've had in
your life who've had a net positive
impact on your life add them all up
how many stand out because that's one
thing I think a lot of us don't talk
about when we're talking about the
teacher so sort of the dialogue the
national conversation well a second what
should matter most is how many teachers
have really helped you and I can count
them on one hand yes they taught you
that just by their it's for before so we
don't know that producing with me in
video studio as always as go2 is not a
foam and twittered not gauge you had me
touch creditor with your comments your
thoughts your photoshop's by the way
we're gonna have an art contest send
them in I fulfill my legal operations or
any conclusions we good I won't be
judging because I'm not gay I don't know
what that has to do with anything that
was a horrible stereotype that G Morgan
Jr IG Morgan Jr how are you I'm doing
well sir and in the spirit of summertime
Cakebread cellars Sauvignon Blanc oh wow
really the reason brother is because you
got a discount because the season is
over
just like back-to-school sales he does
that with liquor and computer I'm good
people I'm ready with you over lace and
yeah you can send me you can fit me I
just realize I I plugged you and then
you plugged you is it man that means I
have to fire you that means nose fan can
other news to get to we're gonna be
talking obviously about Donald Trump and
Russia that's the main story of the day
but first more important Dennis Rodman
has invited Kanye West to North Korea to
create songs for leader leaders of love
here's the actual video he tweeted to
Kanye West in its entirety because you
deserve it
what's up Kanye's d-rod here man over
there now
you know Newport Beach man thanks a lot
for that shoutout man with the jersey
man
lovely work lovely stop love your wife
here's a beautiful a man I'll talk about
something this mean you do a track
together man about world peace about
leaders of love maybe about leaders of
love
you're one I'm one let's get together
baby and do this right I don't know okay
I don't know what fur stuff they talk
about coat tailing hey Kanye West let's
do a track to get it because I think
what equals I'd be lying if I wasn't a
little bit resentful that these these
are her representatives yes be like
Kanye is taking Rodman for a street ball
but naming himself captain oh yeah
exactly I kind of want to see that
though I want to see them team up well
you have to appreciate his passion what
it was just weird to you that he you
seem to really like Kanye's wife took
like a little pause they're like why no
I mean he really likes Kanye's wife see
the next video he released hey thanks
again for the shadow you made me so
happy and I wanted to follow up I love
you so much man and you're the man and
and I love your wife man and and I was
thinking this song maybe we could do a
music video that does make me so happy
man and you could be in it and me and
Kim Jong and give your wife and oh that
makes me so happy man we can we can have
your wife dance you like it in that
video when you're like going with video
with the motorcycle and and I think it'd
be great for the American and for the
North Korean people man and she'd be
wearing like like they slip so you can
you like see up the side of it and I'd
love to have it man old motor so she'd
be backwards on that motorcycle because
me and her Wow yeah we have two whole
black guys on our side and I still feel
really uncool yes pretty much
- and if you end that up with the person
who does the rants on Facebook and carry
the one two and a half - - sorry for
Alabama police officers have now been
suspended for making a hand gesture on
local ABC in the Jasper Police
Department they were suspended for
making a hand gesture while posing for a
photo they did this little thing some
people claim the circular gesture was
racist according to the city's mayor and
here's something else too there was also
some speculation the gesture is actually
part of a children's game or did you
ever play this yeah of course you get to
you get to hit the ball of them yes yeah
and fun so when years it's not really
that surprising given the other games of
department band including Rock Paper
Scissors Red Rover
induct up Jew because of the diverse
they've had and it turns out by the way
once they found out was just handed
people have been suspended for hand
gestures before mister pretty common
Harvey Weinstein at last year's Hunger
Games premiering that didn't go nor Bill
O'Reilly's new show but really if you
fits not a hand gesture okay it's like
yelling fire in a crowded theater it's
more the action that goes with it here's
the thing best-case scenario if they
really were fired for a white power as
they caught us on the in the article a
white power gesture the black power
phase is literally part of the Twitter
brain did black lives matter so I don't
be the guy points out blatant hypocrisy
but I kind of want to play I do there's
a plain connotation with black power and
white power these are the a shade this
land whale and I say this we have to
because some this person in a bikini
walked down the streets of New York to
prove a point
Cosmo and O'Brien you know what trigger
warning and what's what's fun she said
she was expecting to be quote fat shamed
instead you know but were actually into
it shouting things like I want to suck
on them tasty toes and quote from the
article
let me butter them biscuits and by the
way cuz it's gets so much worse but I
read the article in the man's defense he
was actually yelling at the Popeyes
across the street which see when you
take him on where Ana immediately went
afterwards the family meal and two diet
cokes next week bomber actually
suppresses the fact that two diet cokes
actually cancels out the carbs yes yeah
it is science science she said I was
prepared to be point of that shame I
didn't expect to be fetishized
however count your lucky stars that
somebody was into it or Al she's also
being disingenuous because given that
she sought out and performed sets done
at the corner of Martin Luther King jr.
Malcolm X Boulevard PolitiFact actually
rated her statement a size 25 pants on
fire so that didn't go over well there's
something else do a lot of people listen
once while they do they do there's a
huge difference for tell me this between
fat pride and slightly overweight women
yeah exactly this comes off to I just
there's no good way I washed I feel
pretty with Amy Schumer bad decision my
wife said let's just watch it it's a
long night ice cream - no I just anyway
it's as bad as you would think are such
a masochist I actually didn't think I
trained I thought she could be I think
I've always said she was funny at one
point I know I'm in the minority I don't
I don't hate her I don't I think she was
very funny just not anymore
so one note but I'm sitting there
talking with my wife gonna listen every
single other woman including the extras
they're all attractive the only one
who's not as Amy Schumer men don't
expect you to be perfect so don't think
that when we when we point out someone
who's a size 25 saying this is perfect
this is we don't know for a second
it's fine to be big skinny tall short
not perfect once you say you're perfect
I'm accidentally if I carry ously living
the movie through year you ready for
stars in his head now that's what we
were saying and you said it happens on
both ends actually in one's very
acceptable yeah and one is not so we're
not making fun of this girl at all what
we're saying is hold on oh no no I as a
person when she goes out in public poses
in a bikini and people actually are into
it and she said that creeped her out
more than being fat she can't win if I
walk the streets I feel like people are
looking at me because I'm a size 36 NFL
if you look at me because they were
tricked what do you want tell us what
you want what do you what do you want
what do you do by the way this goes
either way I've had my mom my mom is a
thin woman my wife sits in a woman and
actually hurt her she comes bite
honestly both her parents nor naturally
very thin yeah they've actually the
opposite problem where they've had to go
to doctors just to increase calorie
intake skittles so it's natural it's a
lot and I've had women send them like we
we only have sizes for real women in the
store to their face is she a figment of
your imagination she's right there yeah
we we don't expect women to be perfect
but when you say you're perfect and
you're a land whale how do you make it
into the show yes okay the New York
Times by the way else is right now
reporting that Donald Trump was shown
Intel illustrating that Putin directly
ordered cyber attacks in 2016 New York
Times said it so you know it's good so
Trump's be true took to Twitter this one
of course it was fake news and he said
they were trying to quote so recklessly
hard and hate the fact that I'll
probably have a good
should shoot with Putin I'm not a Donald
Trump hater but a muzzle might not be a
bad investment every once in a while
what oh oh muzzle I thought you said
Muslim or Indonesia or by are you a year
everywhere Muslims congregate
progressive right uh but here to speak
about that more he's been pretty
passionate he's been on shows and you've
seen his political ads former chief
White House Ethics lawyer now candidate
for Richard painter thank you for being
here sir that's a not happy about what
his handling of Russia if you were to
put a finer okay so then what what's
your solution American people a dog a
dog he's trying to say don't mean you
can kiss it I don't think that's okay
that's an odd reference to make I think
is it a swamp fire just put out the fire
with its own swamp you know what we
apologize to our viewers and wish only
the best for Senator perhaps senator
painter I hope he finds what he's
looking for okay moving on with other
things it'll be wildly unpopular you
know we have a fete we've offended
although you know what the truth is we
can actually get a lot of emails from
people in comments if we want going like
yeah you know what I'm slightly big and
this doesn't offend me at all I can't
stand those people yeah they're called
called everybody else on the bell curve
they occupy all of it
you're just a curve hit the notification
bell and join my club if you people
haven't yet joined welcome it's the only
way to support this show we don't we
don't keep the lights on with YouTube
and of course livestream every every
Thursday 8 p.m. Eastern it's never
changed ok so this was an article in
Time magazine called it's the only way
these teachers are working summer jobs
to make ends meet to the violins this is
going to be a little bit of an unpopular
opinion it's time for another sacred cow
cookout
we could probably that could stand to be
improved printed where you had to take
off the edges yeah so unpopular opinion
but stay with me yeah all right
I not all teachers okay I think it's an
important job I'm not saying not the
most important job but we'll get to that
I think some teachers underpaid but I do
think that public school teachers in
particular have devolved into a
professional culture of victimhood and
ingratitude this was an article but it
read very much like a dramatic 20/20
special so that's how were going to
present it here it is well done
summer break technically started in May
18th but he works every day he wakes up
and drives to a space he's rented an
office building in Lawrence Kansas
starting a seven hour shift at around
5:00 a.m. as a transportation consultant
advising on long-distance chemical
hauling before clocking out at noon to
go spend time with his kids okay if you
weren't aware of the agenda at play here
if this would actually read like a very
mild workday Wow that's it that's
awesome this is how you lead the horror
story I haven't walked a short seven
hour shift since I was 21 years old I
was probably 16 it's been a long this
hands been forced to work the every day
9:00 to 3:00
I know it's 9:00 to 4:00 I exaggerated
with one to make a point because I think
I've earned it here it's all a far cry
from Dunn's normal routine for most of
the year he's a high school math teacher
but school's out through August and his
salary doesn't cover his four-year-olds
preschool tuition or eight-year-olds
dental expanders done must supplement
his job with an income from a summer job
okay ah time for a leftist lexicon
school's out equals vacation okay let's
be really clear about this honest summer
vacation for a reason yes and and and by
the way again we work with some people
who are teachers who actually work on
this show part-time okay brilliant
people it's not all teachers but the
ones who talk on this article pretty
damn
I've had it with you uh and summer job
or as it's interchange in this article
second job really means job for
everybody else yeah we don't get three
months off we don't get to an f-1 stuff
we don't get one month off no glad you
cleared that up for everybody also the
title it's the only way can be
substituted with this is one of a
multitude of ways but I want more money
as well as three months off so I'm going
to do it this way and then [ __ ] about
it and then I'm gonna protest when it's
really not about the kids it's about me
making more money for working less time
than the average children really hold on
strike that your honor does it have to
be on the record you're right I already
done deal here it goes I go the more
guns not alone in having a summer side
hustle educators are statistically
thirty percent more likely to have
second jobs than non teachers okay
that's Alexa come second job equals job
and frankly I find this number
surprising when you hire I'm horrible at
math and I caught this when you consider
the average American job is 260 plus
days per year
teachers are only contracted to work 185
days per year good gig I'm surprised
it's only 30% that means that if you I'm
not good at math hold on carry the one
70% of features don't
that's called significant they get to
have their cake and eat it three months
out of the year to the 3.1 million
public school teachers in the u.s.
earned an average of only 59 thousand
dollars during the 2016-17 school year
according to the National Education
Association labor union wait did you say
only yeah I know okay
really so this is about six thousand six
hundred dollars a month okay prorate
that to a 12 months 12 months job and
it's close to 80 thousand dollars it's
like 79 thousand dollars that's 20
thousand more to the national median
income of fifty nine thousand okay
that's median by the way not even
average that's a lot of money that's
more money than I pay my employees is
that a bad thing
it is a terrible thing make the work
every day of the year except for you
know if you think about that this is not
to to to I'm not trying to tar and
feather all teachers this is one of
those subjects I think people are
getting a little bit tired of it
yes you can't it's the most important
job how about neurosurgeon is that in
there somewhere
PR doctor perhaps and we're just saying
all teachers listen you taught social
studies right okay you did creaking
that's not exactly your fame is
economically this is Frizzle no exactly
well and one of the reasons we bring
this up is because you guys go on strike
all the time for very obvious reasons
you want to get paid more money and
you're in a teachers union that then
lobbies the government to set your pay
well by the way politically we'll talk
about big money and Koch brothers not
even close
should be it should be illegal and you
you cry to us every single time it's
about the kids it's about the kids and
for most of you are a lot of you I don't
know the number it's about kids but when
you're out there asking for a 20% raise
like in Arizona we haven't been there
yet to it sorry I have to step on
something you got foreshadowing back to
2020 it's also expensive to work in
education 94% of US public school
teachers report paying out of pocket for
supplies spending an average of four
hundred and seventy nine dollars a year
again I'm horrible at math are you
serious
that's $40 less than an intern pays out
of pocket for a smart phone she had to
buy Crayolas on her own dime
I have 20 care Mountain receipts I just
have never turned in because I'm how
about we just pay them five hundred
dollars a year less and give that money
to students for supplies problem solved
it's not coming out of their pocket
anymore yes it's good that's not what
knocking resna turn in it's because you
can't expense report a ball gag it's
true I have tried away so this show yes
you could we literally have I think
twice twice twice one of them my mother
had to do it that's an uncomfortable
that's an uncomfortable excel sheet
here's the thing most people I think
have some kind of gripe with their jobs
yeah most in our hearts just are
naturally our hearts are oriented toward
the state of lack of gratitude and a
gratefulness right teachers just have a
lot more time to get together a [ __ ]
about anything but people yes stop it I
have to tell them to use a number-two
pencil so that it doesn't mess up the
scantron machine when I put it in that's
still the tech
number freezing for look like I'm
talking to a wall
to reiterate just rescind to be specific
three months more time than everybody
else let's say - let's say - let's be
really daring but they still you
scantron how does that say do they even
have not number two pencils I've never
seen one what is this a thing I don't
know I always say a number two but what
happened number one what happened number
one do we just get rid of and never give
it any kind of acknowledgement credit
for what stood I guess we just
contributions will be remiss if we skip
it Oh more from the bush ooh
that's what fueled a nine day teachers
strike this past March in West Virginia
because they're doing a great job and we
have the word magic record teach after
teachers found out they'd only be
getting a 2% raise they organized aa
mass eventually forcing the governor to
increase their pay by 5% and paws health
care price hikes protests for higher
wages quickly spread everywhere from
Oklahoma to Colorado oh okay
a 5% raise is far above the average of
3% annually for American work yeah all
right
and like you said teachers elsewhere in
Arizona got a 20% rate that's insane
across the board after one strikes
sounds like greediness is contagious and
they didn't teach the kids 20% better
the tech 20% more all right it's golden
20% more on times and 20% less scantron
at that point talking about - this is
where like we're talking about with it
with the fat pride deal what it is is
the grace window closes when there's
ingratitude right yeah if you want it if
you if teachers just okay listen it's 3%
we want a 3% raise 5% raise okay let's
go with that at that point but let's say
someone says you know what I I'm gonna
give you a 6% race that's twice a
national have they're excited to give
the teachers but you say 20% guess what
yeah you think that person wants to be
gracious to you you're done you think
the public the taxpayers
you think they're happy with this
performance it's the exact opposite
ingratitude closes doors and people and
that's why I say that the tides are
shifting right now with a lot of
teachers particularly as you have more
private schools particularly have more
people doing a school online yeah
there's a lot of competition not all
teachers are great we'll get to that in
a second yeah back to the boys as teens
dropped summer jobs
teachers likes the sullens are picking
them up forget lifeguarding are
delivering newspapers
state educators are taking advantage of
the gig economy some walk dogs through
wag a pet-sitting app or some delivered
packages for Amazon flex where employees
can earn up to $25 an hour okay
you only work nine months out of the
year so you're forced to take a
completely flexible name your own hours
high paying part-time work to get fired
job thanks to the modern economy by the
way during your two months vacation
because you only make the equivalent to
twenty thousand more than the national
average plus lifelong benefits and by
the way this sharing economy the gig
economy is the economy that all the far
left is to support your unions 99% of
the time look it up at open secrets hate
the socialists hate the sharing Academy
and a B&B or pick up you won't socialist
coot irony is too rich the sullens sorry
Sullins is a first name I need I need to
trigger this great kisser like oh you
had it the spirits the same boy
white guy named Sullins who was a
master's degree in his national board
certified says he earns about
forty-seven thousand a year in base pay
he can usually bring in about two
hundred dollars every few days with
lifts with why money he uses to them to
help cover auto bills and medical costs
for him and his husband last year he
worked in a religious priests school I
don't even know what I'm just gonna
flush this up I wish I could take
vacations I wish I could sit and do
nothing during the summer he says don't
we all I don't think teachers are really
paid for the value of what they provide
to society like teaching them about two
daddies just in case the social agenda
weren't obvious enough they just
definitely caught that him and his
husband are teaching children and they
would love to take summers off feather
the to Daddy thing in there right yeah
it's not that a religious preschool what
what religion I don't know maybe maybe
they're Unitarians they have schools I
don't know Unitarian Montessori School
except except Christian here's something
I guess I've had some great teachers
yeah but if had
when you average it up most of you have
had somewhere between in candidates a
little bit different I did immersion so
I've had somewhere close to 40 teachers
by the time I was in college right yeah
most people have somewhere between 25
and 40 would go through grade school and
high school okay uh I can name you for
that had a positive impact on my life
can you can you touch can you think of
any think of you think of it I can think
of probably two that had a big impact
and maybe two or three others that had a
a good impact but I can't remember the
names no but one of them was one of
these remember me always yeah next year
who is she do you have any teachers I
was home-schooled so I plead the fifth
yeah yeah you can't do that any good
teachers oh yeah a few good teachers
what do I didn't they beat you a lot in
Germany switch yeah you get better
results that wrap in the paddle I can
count on one hand so I can get into the
exact names mr. Mitchell my senior year
English teacher
that's Centennial and I remember he was
very clear about how you were graded
okay you had to read a book and you had
to write an essay on the book you had to
deliver an oral each semester need to do
a written test on the book and then you
had to do a written test on something
like kind of grammar and then you also
had 10% of your grade just for writing
every single day in a journal he said if
you do these things and this is how
you're graded and kids loved him he
stayed after class and the school board
came to him and told him that his grades
were too high so he just took it down by
five points next semester so he wouldn't
get fired see this is why we hate
schools mrs. Berman taught me about
World War two the Holocaust the ninth
grade she was one of the few like
board-certified people and while she
reprimanded me she actually encouraged
kind of the class clowns Minh ship that
you see today she's like you're being a
smartass you can do it just not on my
time I find it funny but I will kick you
out now we know who to blame
you could have nipped it in the bud I
can remember mrs. Roberts but in my
seventh grade homeroom teacher stayed
after school to to help me with with my
math and then this is Naidoo here's a
good example strict fierce small I think
South Indian lady she was very dark
darker than most black people I mean it
was she was really dark
yeah camouflage and most kids didn't
like her most kids did not like her so
it was that year by the way in the
fourth grade it was my whole childhood
up until Quebec or midway through that
year I had to be in French immersion and
I think I've swelling with you guys
about this that's where you do half an
English
half in French so I was learning math
you know history geography in French and
I fell behind I think they might have
thought it was learning disabled I'm not
entitled but the point is midway through
the year for some reason all I knew was
they switched me to learning English
learning in English and I was fine once
I started learning in English was like
oh he's he's not [ __ ] he's slow
doing math in French let's say you mean
I'm speaking a language it's very
difficult trying to learn math which I
don't know yet
right seriously and it didn't have so
much to do with math it was just really
hard for me so mrs. Naidu stayed after
school and she taught me long division
which I can't do now
I cannot remember we have calculators
don't worry the crazy thing is it took
about three sessions yeah
and same with my senior year of high
school I never opened my math textbook
because I had a teacher I won't name him
reelect him as a person horrible math
teacher 73 percent of his students would
fail their provincial exams but three
sessions for me to learn long division
which I didn't learn all think of that
half of the school year nothing nothing
you get nothing good day sir your
learning-disabled good day to you the
school system the public school teachers
taught me in three sessions with a truly
devoted teacher I learned it all I'm not
condemning all teachers what do I think
let me simplified I think miss Naidu
deserves a six-figure executive salary
and the other teachers is her intern
base pay there you go in a nutshell yeah
absolutely I have a quick easy solution
to this if you take the school system
that we have right now and you make
people compete for jobs teachers are
gonna make a lot more money every one of
them could possibly get a raise if you
take it out of the government sector and
put it in the public sector oh is that
really what you think when you think
it's performance-based and this
intrinsically paternal system look at
Mathieu oh you use words that you pulled
out of his harvard dictionary doesn't
intrinsically paternal system has
nothing to do with competitive base pay
yeah also I have a I have a buddy who is
a teacher right now and we love that the
good teachers we love them obviously
you've said that before my buddy's a
great teacher but he chooses to do it he
knows he's going to make less money and
so therefore he doesn't complain when he
makes less money yeah it works a second
job he chooses to do because he loves
the fulfilling aspect of it he gets to
sew into people and that's fantastic go
for it but don't then complain to me
that you want three months off and more
money and the longer you do it you know
what you're hurting of it just like the
size 25 the size 36 personally told me
she hurts the women who
are slightly chubbier because the more
you demand that people accept you is
perfect the more you demand that
everyone take you for what you are and
take it at face value for perfect the
less grace people have for you teaching
is the single most important job in the
world now if you said listen I think
teaching is an important job you have a
lot of grace from people going out oh
yeah that's an important tip it's the
most important well doctor person
separated conjoined twins at the head
what you do today
nasod it's the most important teachers
are the most underpaid yup on a second
not necessarily
what about anesthesiologists they're off
by a degree you get killed I know
they're paid a lot I want them to be
paid a lot I've been put under twice I
want them to be good at their jobs if
you just said teachers are generally
underpaid most people go along with you
how can you close people miss more
opportunities in their life for
ingratitude then I think it's just just
an attitude of gratitude it's not about
being great this false sort of positive
self help it is about appreciating what
you have and using that as your platform
from which to propel yourself word you
will open doors by being grateful people
will want to be gracious to you
all right speaking of very gracious not
gay Jared forced me to do this it is
time for a Mudd Club movie review
[Music]
[Applause]
what do I have to review there knock at
your we are come reviewing today um
Mamma Mia - want me at - yeah say yeah
it ain't so so well you don't have to
you weren't there so let me just give
you the synopsis because I can't really
tell you what happened in 1979 these
girls don''t onion Rosie graduate from
Oscar University don't free to embark on
her journey she meets Harry bill and Sam
and falls in love with Sam but ends at
primary okay here's the deal
we saw a mama Mia - I threw up a lot
Mamma Mia - I'm pretty sure it's just
based on out and by the way getting a
little bit thin with the Abba greatest
hits catalog I hope there's not a three
and dear God no Pierce Brosnan because
I'm like again I want to like he's so
fantastic via I have a lost respect for
him for those of you who have not seen
it here's a brief clip
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now for hopper proverbs sponsored
exclusively by mud club they said that
if you give a dog some cheated you feed
him for a day but if you give a dog a
cow
I don't well I don't know how to make
chillies but if I diversify some thumbs
a Papa could figure it out just on my
club so Steven can give Harper more
teases because he has thumbs stay tuned
for more hopper proverbs sponsored by
mug club
[Music]
I don't think people can do hadouken x'
in real life we've been asking for fans
but if someone could it would be our
next guest so for people who don't know
I'm not gonna lie there are very few
I've talked about this people have met
in my life who intimidate me not just
because I can beat the crap out of me
but there's a certain level of fame and
notoriety with which I'm no longer
comfortable one was when I met Clint
Eastwood III didn't know what to say
like I loved doing every which way but
loose he introduced himself as the mayor
of criminality and he ministries himself
as the mayor of Carmel one was GSP and
our next guest in case you don't know
undisputed light heavyweight champion
boom just defeated ste paimio chips to
become the undisputed heavyweight
champion boom
Andy is a full time host and commentator
for the sports of sport of mixed martial
arts
Daniel DC Cormier how are you sure thank
you for being here I'm pretty good man
thank you for having me Steve I
appreciate you calling us from your from
your limo there I see someone who's
driving I hope to reach that level of
notoriety someday it's it's a like you
know you stated off air it might be a
bit of a Power Move you know we got to
seem real busy got to keep it moving yes
exactly well I don't I don't really
think you need to make a power play DC
rest assured everyone here is terrified
so first off listen congratulations
obviously and what might be one of the
biggest accomplishments in sports let
alone mixed martial arts everyone I know
wants to talk about the Lesnar fight
they want your ear on this this is the
big biggest fight coming up but for some
of our fans who aren't necessarily
familiar I'd love to kind of get into
your story a little bit yes I mean some
serious adversity you've overcome your
yes people don't know captain of the
Olympic wrestling team and really really
high hopes for you because you were so
high level and you had kidney failure
from cutting weight dialysis yes not to
bring up any sore spot but obviously a
tragedy with your daughter things that
most people would justifiably use as an
excuse now you have us become the UFC
heavyweight champion at 39 and having
had yeah Brian Shaw recently World's
Strongest Man and George st. Pierre and
some great people at what they do how
did you do it did you always believe and
know that you were going to be here
what's that like what are the doubts
like along that path huh you know man
the crazy thing is it's like when you
when you deal with a lot of these things
that I've dealt with you know especially
the tragedies in life you can either
suck it up or you can say you know what
my journeys done you know I knew that
the best way to honor all the people
that I've lost especially Kayden was to
do something truly truly special so use
it as a motivating factor in my life and
that's what I've done I feel like all
the the the near the the very close
calls I had would be coming the best led
to that moment on them on July 7th our
July 9th my thoughts beeping come on
that's a big elaborate Victor give or
take
give or take a couple of days I have a
lot of things going on so far I'm trying
to really make myself seem more busy
than I am I really did know the date I
didn't know you guys called yeah but you
know we I doubt myself you know I'm like
man 39 years old you know you know what
the craziest thing was like before the
fight with Steve a being that he was the
guy that defended the bill three times
he's the most successful heavyweight
champ of all time yeah I'm in the back
in the locker room and I'm walking back
and forth and he's the thoughts of them
have it to myself because my coaches and
teammates are all excited I'm telling
myself when I lose I'm 39 years old I'm
done with this I'm never fighting again
I don't need to deal with this anxiety
it's over I was like I was like trying
to give myself reasons why I was gonna
lose the fight it was like what is going
on I could have trash talk he always
mumbles people from Cleveland I don't
know what they're saying it just makes
no sense yeah any reason it was just and
it was just like everybody was saying
how hard he hit right and I'm like man I
wonder just do is gonna hit I'm like
what in the world it just hit me what
types of questions but the moment I got
into the Octagon I was like I could
never give this up I can't give this up
until it's time to me to give it up but
you know it's I'm interested in the fact
that you mentioned that you know anxiety
some fighters say they don't get it same
thing with the performers you know
before I take the stage ever I'm always
nervous and I've always been very
jealous of some people who say they're
not but you're someone who who gets
nervous before every fight I think you
should embrace that do you know because
I feel like free
you and me the people that are nervous
it's like it's like this anxiety for me
it's competitive nerves right like I I'm
excited about the opportunity to compete
and test myself and challenge myself but
not knowing what the outcome is gonna be
you know makes me on alert and I feel
like the time that I'm not like that is
when I'm gonna lose a fight and I feel
the same way with you right like if
you're going on to a stage you know you
have a job to do you know you have the
message to get across and it's like if I
don't get if I don't present my message
in a good strong way this can go
sideways very quickly so yeah they're
great the nerves make you want a janitor
picking a job to the level that you
expect from yourself yeah I often still
go sideways from live performances
because people punch me what I have to
say okay I have some other questions I
want to ask you but let me ask this
specifically about about that fight
because now understanding I didn't know
this you know the anxiety that sort of
self-doubt you had had I remember
watching it and you starting off and
being a little bit more cautious and I
turned to my dad watching this fight for
people who don't know go watch it it's a
classic setting up he's timed him now
and I remember your hands were a little
bit up you fight taller than a lot of
people talk about that with you and yet
rolled with the punch as he pivoted
seemed like you rolled that a thousand
times did you kind of get a sense when
you're in there going okay I've been
here before I know it's about to happen
you know you know he will not when I was
wondering about his punching power once
I felt it I was like okay this is
nothing abnormal you know this is right
he is hard but nothing that I have it
nothing that I haven't uh my kids that's
Ken I'm also like hey I'm super busy
driving the car and raising my kids
while doing the interview look I
appreciate I am a busy man I'm just
kidding but uh I was like okay it's not
abnormal I kind of got his timing a
little bit let's see what happens but
when he went to that underhook I I live
to get my underhook because time and
time again early in the fight I tried to
uppercut him right right we had picked
up on something steep a does when he
looked back side of the clinch he'll
leave his hands low and his Chin's kind
of up yeah so after I live for him that
time I had to uppercut twice I was like
he's gonna expect upper cut his hand
stayed a little bit low side through the
over hook and it landed I mean it's
something that me and my coaches
especially resent old Sanchez did over
and over again we went uppercut hook
over the top uppercut hook over the top
and once it presented itself
he disappeared from in front of me and I
was like oh my goodness
this is actually happening right now
yeah well it was like a fairy tale don't
take your foot off the gas there's I go
my goodness and he's up crap crap and
we've seen sleep a do that right went
over him dropped him he got up and he
got back and he won that fight but hey I
was like oh my goodness he's down jump
on him and hit him a couple more times
then justify yes and this was on July
7th correct just making sure how does it
how does it feel at this moment in time
to know that you are virtually 100%
certain there is no man walking the
globe who could defeat you an unarmed
hand-to-hand combat at this moment in
time you know they say the heavyweight
champion is the baddest man on the
planet and I'm the UFC heavyweight
champion so it's a it's a good feeling
whenever you accomplish things that you
look forward to you your entire career
you know I I've come up short before so
to accomplish that goal and be the guy
that was so well thought of it's big
thing is with needle I'm a shorter guy
right I'm not the most muscular guy
right so guys I wouldn't know what would
he say that DC I would say Europe I
would say you're about average or a
good-looking guy yeah I'm a good-looking
guy I'm beautiful I'm beautiful
yes in my wife but people wouldn't try
sleeping because he's six for 250 pounds
right they see me I'm 511 240 pounds
like I might be able to work that dude
yeah
disclaimer don't try me okay all right
well okay let me get more specific
because it's a very gracious answer Josh
Barnett won it to me we can bring up
this clip I don't think you can see it
right now but one of the most amazing
moments in all of fighting you throwing
Josh Barnett and I know you have a lot
of love for him so I don't say this to
at all denigrate the guy like a small
child and for those who don't know
watching Josh Barnett is a tremendous
wrestler who could throw any of us like
a small child when you're fighting one
of the top water UFC champion himself
one of the
wrestlers around and the discrepancy is
so huge between you and someone like
that in this fight does that confidence
carry into the next fight or is it still
back 2.0 and you have those doubts in
that anxiety I always have the
nervousness that that will never go away
but when I fought Josh Barnett I knew
that I was ready to fight everybody
that's was the that was the fight where
I felt I grew up like I was like man I
am a true martial artist now I can fight
anybody in the world and be okay because
I know that Josh could have fought
anybody in the world and been okay so
yeah Josh I always say the Josh Barnett
fight is the fight that I grew up in
okay yeah it was it was the fight that
um I was so terrified my balls retracted
into my body that's how I remember when
you see a 250 man pound men twirled
around oh my god oh okay you just you've
done some recreational boxing there's
make nice watch your pay-per-view and a
box of cotext yeah somebody out there
that could do that to me and that is a
scary thought oh I've had it I've had it
done to me with action Oklahoma State
wrestler suplex me to high heaven and I
was like okay I understand this level
was a guy named he was very nice I don't
want to put out his name but he was very
let me say this very nice and I was the
one who started standing because I
wanted to I think his name is trains a
guy okay gotten in Dallas and just
unbelievably strong in two feet I say to
everyone you should feel excellence in
any realm
now I've had Thomas soul on the show one
of the most brilliant economists ever to
talk with him is to experience in a new
level to go with someone like that who's
an all-american it's just you assume
you're gonna get your ass kicked but you
need to feel at once yeah you know what
I mean okay yes exactly I don't need to
try it with you Skype is good enough
it's something I've always found really
interesting you just mentioned your wife
you know your rivalry obviously with
John Jones
yet so much the fight game aspect but
such a stark contrast I've always
thought in lifestyle with him
hit-and-runs popping hot nightclub
pretty seen as a selfish guy
whereas you seem to really focus on your
family and I always notice sharing your
victories very graciously with teammates
do you think that those relationships
really ground you and make you stronger
as a person thereby as a fighter yes it
does you know because the reality is I
could never do any of this without my
family all with my teammates and my
coaches like yeah from the moment that I
first experienced high level mixed
martial arts especially watching Cain
Velasquez become heavyweight champion
everything he said was we we thought we
thought we thought we could do this we
thought we could do this and and I
remember going he isn't taking full
credit for this this is a team and I was
like you know what I'm part of that team
and then I started to experience it for
myself like wow it really is this team's
victory I'm just a guy that gets to go
out and show what we've been working on
for the last 12 weeks the last 10 weeks
I'm just a guy that goes out to present
the product I mean nobody does their job
on their own and I believe that when
guys go I'm this and I'm that and I'm
not she's very very selfish but family
is everything you know you don't want
unit it's just that that that that that
real that real kind of crazy type of
life yeah
honestly is not for me you know it's for
its obviously for Jones yeah but it's
also what makes Jones so good right
because he lives he lives so like like
on the edge like I think he might be
like one of those guys that needs to
live on the edge so when he lives on the
edge he also fights like that right like
not many guys can just be absolutely
free inside of the Octagon and I think
Jones is one of those guys that's why
you see him doing spinning kick yes baby
elbow yeah you know he does all these
things because there there's no concern
for what's gonna happen no no concern
for the UH the punishment of the action
and I think that's why he's so good at
fighting but also I saw some instructive
right in life so I'm safe it's healthy
psyche yeah it's a healthy cycle the
creative fighting goes hand in hand with
coconut the Octagon wonder when they're
coming in well you know it's fine this
is a great example of humility and not
in the sense that listen you know you're
the baddest man on the planet
you're not lying about that
false humility but gratitude to people
who helped you do that we're talking a
lot about masculinity this idea of toxic
masculinity today I think you'reyou're a
good example so people can understand
that there's there's a balance between
gratitude and also being real in looking
yourself in the mirror and not to stay
on a sore spot but this is the final
question I do do you want to ask on that
that man you've beaten every man you've
ever fought obviously soundly not named
John Jones and then he pissed so many so
many times hot he was melting you saw
two cups like they looked at the Ark of
the Covenant right if is it still
something that it's a rematch that you
want and do you even think it would ever
be possible given how much trouble and
the suspensions he's been into you know
I our business is a partnership right
because as two guys that have to fight
we have to promote the fight we have to
get to the fight we have to do
everything together to present the fight
as it's supposed to be and there's been
a number of occasions what we haven't
you know for John and I the two fights
that we've had we've been scheduled five
times right and for one reason or the
other we haven't fought I would fight
him again I'm a competitor you know I
would love to fight him again I just
don't know if it works in the timeframe
for what I have left in my career you
know I've said for a long time I will
retire by time I'm 40 years old
that's next March you know and when I
started saying it early people thought
there is no way but we had years away
from that date but now as we get closer
I was like wow this guy might be serious
YUM I just don't know when John's gonna
be back and when honestly that's his
fault I mean yeah I can't hold or allow
him to dictate anything that goes on in
my career anymore well man I think it's
a healthy way to look at it because I
know like you said the guy guy was in
your head for a while I mean that was
that was a it was a rivalry for sure you
two did not see that like each other all
right listen I feel like we're familiar
enough now so let me toss you a bit of a
curveball the the Nick is a nickname DC
it's not really a nickname daniel
cormier it's just your nose can we get
some more going here you know this is
what this was my nickname when I first
started fighting at Oklahoma State was a
Zac Esposito is the assistant coach at
Oklahoma State when I was going there
hit pads on my cousin he
they called me to come for Panda and I
was like at the moment I can change that
I changed it the moment oh okay so you
can change that I'm changing it I don't
know I think kung-fu paint is gonna nice
ring to it and I I hate to tell you this
but a lot of people watch this show and
you want of you you might get a few
people now who say in the Kung Fu Panda
but in a nice way anyone it's a lot
better than self given nicknames like
the dentist the skull crusher
I'll take it over that but still I think
we can do a little better could you
imagine Bruce Buffer Daniel kung fool
panda ridiculous the only people that
would enjoyed it are my children
yeah well the hell on your last fight
have Bruce Buffer belted out in his
shark suit and just just let it rip all
right listen I know you're busy and
you're there but you have no idea how
much pride Bruce takes in those suits
those are all custom-made beautifully
for Bruce Buffer and for the bigger
fights you may find just the material is
just phenomenal we share locker rooms
and I call the fights in the the care
that Bruce takes of these suits it is
something to behold
there's a lot of words inside the lining
but like inside the lining there are so
many words and like phrases these
haven't positive affirmations in his
line he's got so much stuff in the line
too dude like the greatest commentator
of all time and I've got the goat it's
like so much in Bruce's jacket it's just
remember Wayne just goes to strip him
naked and take that yeah that's that
instead of the duck reminders don't
forget to say it's time we got it Bruce
on the ground is still this jacket is
out of you to say that somebody like
that would be the funniest thing in the
Octagon somebody pushes brews out to
take the jacket off don't do it because
if the Diaz brothers are listening they
will all right that is Daniel Cormier
you can follow them on the Twitter of
course at DC underscore MMA you can
watch them on television everywhere and
listen man we are every time you fight
we're rooting for you me and my dad
we're huge fans
I really appreciate you taking the time
and
the inside as well man thank you so much
I appreciate you for having me thank you
be well Kevin McGinnis after this I
think hey one library of the week thanks
so much for people who are supporting
the show it means by when I say support
I mean those who've joined the mug Club
ladder with CARICOM /mo Club it's $99
annually 6a9 for students veterans or
active military just entered in as a
promo code and you get to see the show
that we do live every Thursday at 8 p.m.
Eastern every day we do it instead of
just the clips because like we said
YouTube isn't paying the bills you don't
have to join if you don't want to but
this is what allows us to go out there
go on location do the Daily Show
confront people who are dishonest about
journalism do change my mind it's all
put together by you the Mudd Club
members and it's also well we don't have
so many so many commercials for all of
the weird sponsorships that you hear
across a lot of podcasts I mean how many
different containers do you need a lot
of credit comm / mug Club enjoy the show
[Music]
[Music]
directions this is supposed to be really
hard but snot looks like you're pretty
talented at it you found new skills and
now our next guest is pretty natural
is it pretty natural yeah well naturally
oh no I don't feel like I've been it's
all natural these days kids it's all
ball bearings all right at Gavin
underscore Mick Innes he has a show over
there see our TV and I believe her na
kijiye is going to be on his weekend
program here in the coming weeks Gavin
McInnes how are you sir I'm great knock
a jirt is on the show tomorrow night
which is exciting because I was
interviewing homeless people on the
street the other day and they were very
excited about you sir yeah well there
you go there you go there's something
that's gotta count for something
there's hobos in New York City that are
interested were you doing what they have
options oh I just I interview people on
the street for MLS and there's a there's
a popular bum in New York called the
hater hobo zombie yeah and he was like
man wow that's very I thought you were
saying you loved not gay Jarrod which
would lead to more question yeah exactly
it's all the same prouder you love and
should go part of it if you'd like the
stern show you like Robin Quivers I'm
not familiar with these these do this
nomenclature so one thing I will say is
first before we get to anything else do
you like your chair I notice we have the
same chair now I used to have one of
these from a long time ago it's a Herman
Miller used to be great and now it sucks
it hurts it hurts yeah it used to be I
had an old chair and then they've
changed many fat and now it's like
there's this thing digging into my back
it's like The Princess and the pea only
with herniated disks oh well you can
adjust that thing in the back this is
your we're speaking of course of the
Aeon chair it's an $800 chair made of a
smashed fibers where there's no real
bottom of the chair just suspends you
when you fart it goes through the mesh
and into the atmosphere is no leprous
but they won't put in the brochure but
everyone knows that's why you buy all
right listen so have you been following
us that the the bonobos the toxic
masculinity video that's been
circulating here this week I probably
have or I have a bad frontal lobe but my
back lobe is probably very familiar with
it and you have a tremendous right okay
we're gonna show a clip just to refresh
your memory and then get your thoughts
let's go real quick
masculine adjective having qualities or
appearance traditionally associated with
met especially strength and
aggressiveness some of the synonyms are
macho manly muscular red-blooded my
goodness strapping and strong brawny
powerful none of these really sound like
me I think that's what gets us in
trouble is when we say that there's only
one way to be a man so many individuals
they try and fit and it just gets to a
point where it's too much where they are
doing harm to each other so you're
probably familiar with it now um a
couple of things here I noticed some
serious asymmetry going on there and in
an area a real man in the group I know
this is a hot topic of yours but did you
have a seizure when this occurred yeah I
had a seizure inside an internal seizure
but I'm such a real man that I can keep
that to myself and not show it outwardly
okay
all right listen to some of those
adjectives to that they have a problem
with strong men are meant to be strong
I'm not strong well then you're letting
us down it's like beautiful I know we're
not women are not all supermodels but
every woman wants to be pretty we have
this new reinventing the wheel where
there's no rules and a 400-pound woman
with burns all over face is just as
pretty as the top supermodel no second
the burns I don't think we should toss
into the same boat [ __ ] that might be
out of her control especially I'll go
with you if it within that person's
control or not is irrelevant the point
is that some people are prettier than
others some women are more feminine than
others some men are more manly than
others you can't just throw out the
whole definition yeah well there's
nothing to aspire to I look well I
didn't so much mind if funny that they
to promise strong but red-blooded
red-blooded I think we're just like
we're throwing it we're getting a little
loose with what gets tossed under the
umbrella here none of these things
describe me your reptilian what's
happening right now the conspiratorial
YouTube of the Illuminati right they're
going nuts yeah this is in one thing to
Gavin I know you've talked about this
and we obviously people get mad when you
discuss and there's a controversy but
the reality is no one expects all men to
be all these things like you said they
are just good qualities that be
said the left doesn't see strength is a
good quality they see other goals their
goals and the modern man is a socialist
little wimp and what he does is sit at
home all day and be soft and he's
probably the child of a single mom and
he gets a mani and a pedi and I would
say at least between you know
Millennials and and young men today
that's actually the norm the whole like
strong red-blooded I'm tough I don't cry
you know I want to date hot chicks and
party
I think that's becoming a minority so
those guys we just saw are actually the
oppressors they're there that they're
the ones getting people fired they're
the ones making everyone uncomfortable
the real man is is kind of gone well I
don't even listen obviously I don't so
much care right now there's this pickup
culture the hot chicks and party but we
are talking about a young generation of
men who weren't learning how to be
fathers how to be good husbands how to
get leaders of their community you know
this is a big I don't know if you heard
Barack Obama's speech recently where was
he he was abroad he was in South Africa
South Africa that's right and he said
you know I know it's easy to see think
that democracy is gone and it's been
given over to the strongman something
along those lines I'm going to for a
second there's nothing wrong with a
strongman there's something wrong with a
strong evil man because the evil is
amplified but you want a couple strong
good men to keep them in check but the
left sees strength as a negative kind
like the [ __ ] at juice land we
confronted this person threatened
plotted to slash our tires but they
listed I was six two therefore I'm wrong
you must run into solid behind his beard
I saw that yet the Obama clip was Obama
saying men are kind of getting on my
nerves these days there was one where he
was talking about the strong democracy
given over to the strongman you had
darker days yeah we've had darker days
but still you know he use the term
strongman as a pejorative
he's a vile human being isn't he I don't
like him no I think this whole like
don't cry and all that stuff I think it
started in the 70s there was like this
it's all right to cry and that culture
in the 70s was like don't beat up a kid
cuz easy family in it and don't bully
kids cuz they appear to be gay and they
had a point in the 70s but the pendulum
has swung so far the other way said now
it's bullying people who seem too
masculine
being ashamed of being male and every
time there's a college student doing
answering a question in college she has
to get up and say hi I know I come from
a place of privilege and I'm a white
male and I'm cisgendered but I just
think that you know these qualifiers
they have to give so it's become taboo
to be a proud male but here's the secret
the patriarchy this tough-guy thing
built the Western world know where our
gays and women and everyone else safer
so don't get rid of the patriarchy or
you'll end up with something much worse
yeah Isis yes well it's too too
opportunist either the liberals take
over and you got three hundred genders
and you've got trans prisoners molesting
women in jail and and all kinds of evil
story that we just covered today he's
not speaking out of turn yes or secondly
you get the opposite and you have the
the fascist takeover the the Islamists
and you have Sharia law and like we're
seeing in luton in England like we saw
in Iran so yeah it's lose-lose ladies I
know you don't like you and daddy says
it's bedtime and you got to eat your
vegetables but trust me
at least you have vegetables in a bed
someone in Venezuela right now
vegetables but it is absurd it is
absolutely you know a good example of
that you just talked about Islamists and
Sharia law and we're talking about
strongmen been dr. ben Carson caught so
much flak he took a strong stance now
you can't think of someone who sounds
more meek than dr. ben Carson and he
just said I don't believe in sarena in
the Constitution I think they're
incompatible that was a negative to the
left because that was a position of
strength we're not talking about Arnold
or muscles we're talking about strength
of character and they still pounds on
you even if you're dr. ben Carson so why
hide it well Trump came along and he
said what do you I can't call him anchor
babies what do you want me to call them
undocumented workers of civil society
and he goes I'm saying anchor baby and
this whole like man that's really what
trumps 2018 that's that's what the new
America is about just like no we're not
listening to you anymore we're not doing
your bathrooms we're not doing and if
your crazy ideas we're not calling this
racist or that race to start or bowing
to France for climate change and and
making sure that we keep our carbon
footprint in small
possible we're not playing any of your
games anymore right and that's why the
left is so apoplectic that's why Trump
derangement syndrome so huge because
they go wait a minute I need you to play
along with my games I need you to
recognize that you're evil and and
slavery and you stole everything from
the Indians if you take that away I got
nothing
yeah and we're saying you got nothing
well I think it was kind of a theme
today the ingress in gratitude is a
really crippling problem you see that
from the left a good example would be a
parent wanting to teach their son hey
when your dog does one grandpa it's okay
to cry you want to teach them it's okay
for a young man to cry when it's
appropriate but then they have a teacher
going no no it's okay to cry
or whatever so you can't bestow the
grace upon the kid letting them know
when it's appropriate this is okay
because oh that's our off from the left
just like well hold on a second daddy
will give you a cookie and the left
cookies are meals all the time and then
there's no brace and it's we're
importing that culture too with I call
them Emin greats where these immigrants
come here and they won't shut up about
how much this country sucks and you go
eh
you're wrong and it's way better than
York like that woman decline the Statue
of Liberty
she's from the Congo yeah you know
what's going on in the Congo why I'm not
sure I can State on your show but
soldiers were making children rape their
mother well you just did they they were
beheading dozens of their enemy and
putting the heads in a giant pile then
she comes here and she goes
this place is barbaric oh really
yeah no but thank you how about you go
back to the place that made the worst
movie of all time
white gorillas really with laser guns
I've had enough of this no but I think
you're absolutely
I only reason remember that film was
because I looked forward to it so much
they don't hide all the coming since is
that the Burger King and the watches and
Congo was so bad all right you know what
we do have to get going here really soon
Nakia Jerry's going to be on Gavin
McInnes the show this weekend at Gavin
underscore McGinnis and people can sign
up at see RTD right Kevin yes that is
the case where's your mug I thought you
had a mug oh it didn't catch on as well
it's someone else let it fall by the
wayside all right we'll fix that in post
Gavin thank you very much hope you've
had your shots not good Jarrett's coming
your way we'll wrap this up
like on now for hopera proverbs
sponsored exclusively by mug club
it is said that tall fences make
friendly neighbors unless your neighbor
a squirrel because they can call on the
fence and there were chase them but they
can step on the fighter and those guys I
touch stay tuned for more hopper
proverbs sponsored by mug club
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the medium-rare just a
classic drowning dance because when you
have such a fine cut of meat sometimes
you don't need a doctor it up sometimes
you just go with the classic drowning
dance this is this is called there's
still blood there's still blood forming
all the wrong buttons flame mama Mia
yeah blame the mama Mia for a good
though right good though we have a
Daniel thing I hope we have him back on
the show also too in Gavin McInnes yeah
go watch Daniel Cormier fight it's like
a bat out of hell slash little black
ball of hate he looks very very angry
when he fights he really is a sight to
behold
and man doing that at 39 years old
that's pretty inspirational I think it
knows it's kind of a funny trend it of
all the MMA and you know UFC fighters
you've had on the show none of them are
like jerks off air you like you yeah I
think those are like the most toxic
patriarchal rifle on the planet but
they're always just the most
down-to-earth really nice you know guys
you'd feel very comfortable being around
their knife right here the bullies on
the playground but what's the exception
of a couple they tended to be they were
people who were bullied before st.
Pierre was bullied he talked about it I
don't know if Daniel Cormier has talked
about that so much but a lot of lighter
weight classes got a lot of these guys
were bullied they're not people who like
to wield power uselessly what was last
time you heard about Daniel Cormier
beating up someone who was smaller than
I would like to see that I mean yeah
well he doesn't professionally
passionately except they're usually
bigger than him but typically the ego is
in check nice it's kind of the own it is
it's kind of like you're so exhaust when
you've had such a productive day you're
so exhausted here I mean yeah or like if
you do music for a living last thing you
want to do is like go home and just
fiddle around for your own pleasure well
no I don't I don't mean it that way I
mean in a sense that they've they've
expended all of their egotistical energy
in the gym getting their asses kicked by
other people who are better than them
knowing their role that by the time they
come home all that he goes out of them
mm-hmm they've had it beat nada
it does happen that's why I say it's
good for everyone to take up something
new that you're that you're not good at
yep take it up try it challenge yourself
I talk about that all the time and then
something else I definitely I really
appreciate how candid he was about to
his anxiety because you've heard you
know me before shows I've always been
that way even but when we did SMU we'd
you know thousands of people and I just
thought oh my gosh what's gonna go wrong
it's just that it's just the nature its
how I am some people don't feel that way
so I don't I don't think it
she was our show because there's just so
many more things I can go with so many
things you're wrong most regular commute
like the insurance rider not going
through like that worth her the several
hundred thousand dollars worth of
equipment that was a big deal but when I
Fincher it's not coming through for you
but there's a difference between
gratitude and false humility and you see
a guy like him he talked about how
grateful he is to his family he's not
just blowing smoke sand my family has
made me great my team has made me great
it's the guy upstairs kind of thing yeah
exactly he means it and he's not saying
well you know I'm okay but no no he's
like I'm the baddest man on the planet
but you know it's because of these
people and that really want to talk
about gratitude anticip
my entire life changes when I'm living
in in gratitude so when people couple
have been pretty some tough tough love
at the end of at the end of this program
it's like what can you go back to okay
here's something that everyone can do
and it will change your life gratitude
and I mean it in a very practical way
being ungrateful closes doors being
grateful opens doors now give you some
very specific example so you can
understand it but I told this story a
while back and it resonated with some
people grace is something that I think a
lot of people don't understand today you
know I could I talk about it's known as
a kid my parents took us to Toys R Us
remember where it was it was a across
from the Panama bus station in Brassard
next to check swing where was a guy who
looked like the real-life Simpsons comic
book worst film ever he looks just like
him and it was a comic book store so he
went to this Toys R Us store and my
pants it must have been a budget of $15
each I think $10 $15 you can pick out a
toy my brother and I and we went in and
what did we get we got creepy-crawlers
man we pulled together to get creepy
crawlers with it there's going to be in
the commercials remember there's Corbin
green dad added on his rocking chair
look it up and the kids they got him he
wanted so badly to put a spider on my
dad and him to go no real insight into
French for you growing up did you've
watched us in French because I think
that'll be entertaining I wasn't I I
don't know they probably did exist out
sadder for some reason I think I you
know French they tend to be really over
the top so I don't know how you over the
top a kids commercial yeah that's that's
that's why I'm so curious
no the dad would have been a transgender
I don't know that's how that
done it so he left with the creepy
crawlers and we were so excited we were
thrilled and I still feel bad about this
to this day I don't know my dad I my mom
were watching they may not remember but
I felt really really bad about it so we
went back to our car and we found out we
just had the molds we didn't have the
machine so it must have been $15 because
remember the sheen very specifically was
$49.99 I remember that and they had to
they said they had to take us back in
and return it because we couldn't MIT
they're just the molds because we
couldn't afford the creepy crawlers
machine now we had some periods in our
life where we did really well and we had
some periods of life when I look back
that you know my parents struggled and I
didn't maybe understand it or fully
appreciate it this would have been one
of those times in every bird going back
in and being a brat being upset can't we
get the cream listen if they could have
gotten me the creepy crawlers I'm sure
they would have and we had to go back
for you
no they weren't they were your thing I
was being a spoiled little jackass and
they were already being gracious they
were being gracious and taking me to
Toys R Us to get me a toy they didn't
have to do that but because I wanted
something more and I wasn't grateful
they didn't want to do that for me what
do you think after that I got more trips
to Toys R Us or less probably less for a
good I went through a dry spell there
looking back now I know what I remember
cold showers heroine and I remember
here's something else too I went back in
and we got way to get Stretch Armstrong
and he had a wiener dog and I remember
his name but they were mini ones because
we couldn't afford the big Stretch
Armstrong and mine broke right away the
Stretch Armstrong that alarms as torrid
off but my brother our producer Johnny
boy you know I grew up with in high
school when we met him well junior high
he saw the wiener dog toy because it
became one of our favorite toys stretch
Armstrongs little wiener dog toy
it was stretched out and it was really
cool it was a wiener dog who was funny
all the jokes and if just because of if
we'd have had our way if we have had
what we deserved we would have never
experienced it ended up being creepy
crawlers came and went and that wiener
dog was in the house until my brother
went to college I believe but think
about that sometimes grace is is a more
than you deserve and if you're
ungrateful for it man do you close the
door you see like the teachers unions
what if we want 20% what if they're
willing to give you eight do you think
they're more likely or less likely to
help you when you when you have an
attitude that is Andriy I will tell you
this all the time how often have you had
friends or family who you help out
because you want to hmm
I think we actually know we've talked
about this but then you have the friend
the family member who always want
something from you yeah do you want to
help him not as much
not as much your probably give you
probably giving him less than the people
who aren't asking it yeah it's not about
just as that point it's just now just
it's it's the natural reaction of your
heart inside this is like right it's
kind of closing the door a little bit
and the point with gret if you want to
receive grace we learn us as Christians
right if you want to receive grace you
have to be grateful
first off right and it's something that
the person receiving the grace doesn't
get to dictate the terms of the grace we
said tolerance isn't enough I want you
to promote my life to listen I'm fine
with your doing what you want to do but
I'm not gonna put your flag up well I'm
gonna I'm gonna check in my cause and
that Senate do you think I think you're
more of a dick or less you think you're
helping your cause this is what happens
you overreach you're not grateful for
what you have take your pick people do
not want to help you it closes doors and
you'll never know that's the worst part
is you'll never know that the doors are
closed you could take I don't know some
people out there you know we have a lot
of young people listen if the teachers
unions maybe there's someone else you go
in and in you you want a raise great
most bosses aren't looking to screw you
so you go in and you have a boss who
wants to give you a 15% raise but us 460
now I'm just I'm using absurd example
don't cousin ask for 60 percent raise
because it's called 30 and the boss goes
let's say guys soon I was feeling alone
pulled yeah yes yeah okay let's call 45
the boss will sit back and go huh Wow
I was really excited to give I was
really excited to give that kid the
creepy crawlers I was really excited to
get my Stretch Armstrong but instead
because he's ungrateful and demanded
more now I'm gonna give him nothing that
happens more often than you know and you
cannot know but what I do know is when I
wake up and I and I do every day
gratitude the first thing I do is even
when I'm on even when I was very
unhealthy thank you for the relative
health that I do have I am grateful for
this house I am grateful for my wife I
am grateful for my family I am grateful
for the support of friends I am grateful
for the meal bars that I eat in the
morning that only have four ingredients
they're hard to chew but the delicious
and nutritious
I am brave frivolous
all those little things and it your
change is my life you won't you will
have better relationships with your wife
with your family you will do better in
the workplace you will find people react
to you differently
I'm not saying change your personality
but if you can add that add that facet
to your personality gratitude it makes
all the difference because then everyone
else wants to be still grace upon you
when you're an ungrateful little pissant
nobody wants to it's like the spoiled
kid at the party
no one wants that the kid who's great
the kid who's a lot of fun was like hey
high five in your kid straight
let me have my money a give us a little
nip of scotch that's my grandfather do
with me he couldn't stand other kids
because they wouldn't drink the Scotch
because they were not grateful for the
fine liquor that my grandpapa Armand on
my maternal side would bestow upon me
that's the lesson be grateful and drink
your damn scotch
[Music]